267 الف حاله وفاه سنويه في افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء الكبرى نتيجه تناول الادويه
المضاده للملاريا المزيفه وهناك ما يصل
الى 169 الف حاله وفاه مرتبطه بالمضادات
الحيويه المزيفه او التي لا تفي بالمعايير
المطلوبه المستخدمه لعلاج الالتهاب الرئوي
الحاد عند الاطفال ارقام مرعبه يميت تقرير
مكتب الامم المتحده المعني بالمخدرات
والجريمه اللثام عنها ويقول ايضا انما لا
يقل عن
605 اطنان من المنتجات الطبيه في غرب
افريقيا تم ضبطها خلال العمليات الدوليه
في الفتره ما بين كانون الثاني يناير 2017
وكانون الاول ديسمبر 2021
وقال المكتب ان البحريه الرئيسيه في غرب
افريقيا تستخدم لجلب الامدادات الطبيه
المتجهه الى دول الساحل ومن ثم تهرب عبر
طرق التهريب التقليديه عن طريق البر
ويتاجر بكميات صغيره عن طريق الجو
باستخدام الشحنات البريديه او الركاب
التحقيقات كشفت عن تورط مجموعه واسعه من
الفاعلين الضالعين في الاتجار بالمنتجات
الطبيه في دول الساحل بمن فيهم موظفوا
شركات الادويه والمسؤولون العموميون
وموظفوا انفاذ القانون والعاملون في
الوكالات الصحيه والباعه المتجولون تعتمد
دول الساحل بشكل كبير على واردات المنتجات
الطبيه حيث ان الصناعاتها الدوائيه لا
تزال في المراحل الاولى من التطوير وقد
وجد مكتب الامم المتحده المعني بالمخدرات
ان انتشار الامراض المعديه بما فيها
الملاريا الى جانب التحديات المرتبطه
بتوافر الرعايه الصحيه والقدره على تحمل
تكاليفها
يخلقان بيئه يسود فيها الطلب على المنتجات
والخدمات الطبيه دون الوفاء بكامل معايير
السلامه عن طريق القنوات الرسميه هذا
التفاوت بين الطلب والعرض للمنتجات
الصيدلانيه يفسح المجال للاتجار غير
المشروع ويوفر حافزا لانخراط الجماعات
الاجراميه المنظمه
ويغذي الخطر المستمر على السلامه والصحه
العامتين في دول الساحل